je suis médecin chercheur en sciences
cognitives et je vais vous proposer de
participer à une expérience de science
cognitive vous allez regarder une vidéo
sur laquelle deux équipes jouent au
basket et il va falloir que vous
comptiez les passes des joueurs en blanc
concentrez-vous bien parce que il ne
faut pas vous tromper
retenez bien le nombre de passes
maintenant vous allez regarder la même
vidéo mais sans compter
qu'est ce qui s'est passé un certain
nombre d'entre vous se sont focalisés
sur le dès qu'on dépasse et n'ont pas vu
le gorille qui était pourtant en plein
milieu de l'écran
cette expérience démontre que notre
cerveau n'est pas conçu pour faire deux
tâches en même temps si chacune requiert
de la tension il n'en fait qu'une c'est
une contrainte biologique de notre
fonctionnement cérébral
elle est invisible on en a rarement
conscience et pourtant elle envahi toute
notre vie quotidienne
imaginez un enfant de 6ème qui a des
difficultés à sortir ces affaires de son
cartable
il le fait plus lentement que les autres
l'enseignant puisque tous les autres
élèves sont prêts début de son cours et
donne les premières consignes
quand l'enfant relève la tête il n'a
aucune idée de ce qu'il est censé faire
dans la majeure partie des cas on va lui
renvoyer décidément tu n'écoutes jamais
rien alors qu'en réalité il n'a pas
entendu la consigne au même titre que
vous vous n'avez pas vu le gorille cette
limite de notre fonctionnement cérébral
elle a une conséquence majeure sur les
apprentissages dont il faut avoir
conscience
on ne peut pas apprendre en situation de
double tâche cognitive
typiquement un élève qui luttent pour
déchiffrer les mots en lisant un texte
ne peut pas en comprendre le sens un
enfant qui peinent pour tracer chacune
des lettres ne peut pas faire une
rédaction en écrivant à la main
c'est pour cela qu'un des objectifs
majeurs de l'apprentissage de la lecture
et de l'écriture c'est que les enfants
automatise 7 h
le but c'est que l'enfant ne soit plus
obligé de prêter attention au
déchiffrage des mots quand il lit et au
traçage des lettres
quand il écrit alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe
quand un enfant ne peut pas automatisée
une de ses tâches par exemple l'écriture
c'est le cas des enfants dyspraxiques la
dyspraxie c'est un mot que la plupart
d'entre vous n'ont jamais entendu
et pourtant c'est aussi fréquents que la
dyslexie sa touche 5 % des enfants de 6
à 11 ans les enfants dyspraxiques ils
sont obligés de contrôler chacun de
leurs gestes et parfois même les
mouvements de leurs yeux lorsqu'ils
lisent ça veut dire qu'ils sont en
situation de double tâche cognitive
quasiment toute la journée et c'est
particulièrement vrai à l'école puisque
à l'école d'aujourd'hui les enfants en
moyenne passe deux tiers de leur temps à
écrire
prenons la situation de la dictée si
l'enfant dyspraxie doit porter toute son
attention sur le traçage des lettres il
peut pas entendre
en même temps le texte de la dictée
alors il va partager son attention
un petit peu d'attention sur le traçage
des lettres un petit peu d'attention sur
les coudes du texte de la dictée
et bien voyons comment vous réagissez
quand je vous contraint à partager vos
ressources cognitives entre deux tâches
je vais vous présenter des chiffres
vous allez lire dans votre tête et vous
allez essayer de les retenir
on y va
maintenant on va faire la même tâche
mais en même temps vous allez dire bla
bla bla allez-y faites bla bla bla
vous avez remarqué que dans la deuxième
condition c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de retenir les chiffres qu'est ce qui se
passe une partie de vos ressources
cognitives a été accaparé par le bla bla
bla et donc vous n'avez plus
suffisamment de ressources pour retenir
tous les chiffres
c'est la même chose pour l' enfant
dyspraxique qui fait ça dit et une
partie de ces ressources sont accaparés
par le traçage des lettres et il n'a
plus suffisamment d'attention pour faire
attention à l'orthographe
alors on en déduit il a un problème avec
l'orthographe alors même que quand on
lui demande des pelé les mots à l'oral
il ne fait pas de fautes ça c'est vrai
pour tous les enfants
un enfant qui est qu'il faut mais qui
est-elle juste n'a aucun problème
d'orthographe
il est en situation de double tâche
cognitive
quand il écrit alors comment va-t-on
faire pour que ces enfants dyspraxiques
puissent apprendre à l'école
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour qu'ils
puissent être évalués sur la base le
complètement leur compétence scolaire et
non pas en fonction de leurs déficits
moteurs
on pourrait se dire on va les entraîner
ils vont écrire pendant plusieurs heures
tous les jours à la fin ils finiront
bien par écrire comme tout le monde
est-ce qu'on le fait pour les myopes est
ce qu'un seul d'entre vous c'est déjà
dit je vais retirer les lunettes de cet
enfant il va s'entraîner à regarder et à
la fin il finira bien par voir comme
tout le monde
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne le fait pas
parce que ça ne marche pas à la fin il
est toujours mieux c'est pareil pour les
enfants dyspraxiques il n'y a aucune
étude scientifique qui montre qu'en
entraînant de façon intensive les
enfants dyspraxiques à l'écriture
manuscrite
on leur permet de ne plus être en
situation de double tâche quand ils
écrivent
alors pour eux aussi il va falloir
trouver des lunettes
il va falloir construire des outils qui
vont leur permettre de développer tout
leur potentiel scolaire sans être gênés
par leurs difficultés motrices
c'est la mission que s'est donnée le
cartable fantastique
la démarche de l'association consiste à
partir des besoins des enfants et a
croisé le regard de chercheurs et
d'enseignants pour trouver des solutions
qui permettront à ses enfants
d'apprendre de travailler d'être évalué
sans passer par l'écriture manuscrite
évidemment en 2015 ces solutions vont
passer par le numérique
donc on va prendre les exercices qui
sont proposés en classe à tous les
élèves
et puis on va les transformer en
exercice numérique pour que les enfants
dyspraxiques puisse répondre en cliquant
ou en tapant tu la vis quand on fait ça
notre constat c'est que des enfants qui
étaient submergés par leurs difficultés
d'écriture reprennent confiance en leurs
capacités
on les voit se rallumer enfin ils vont
pouvoir montrer ce dont ils sont
capables
il ne s'agit pas de nier leurs
difficultés il s'agit de leur dire c'est
vrai tu as des difficultés avec tes
mains
elles ne font pas du tout ce que tu
voudrais qu'elle fasse mais cela ne te
définit pas en acceptant de prendre en
compte ce qui est au fond uniquement un
problème d'outils ne pas pouvoir écrire
avec un crayon on leur donne toutes les
ressources pour pouvoir acquérir
comprendre manipuler les concepts on
cherche à leur enseigner les enfants
dyspraxiques m'ont appris beaucoup de
choses ils m'ont fait prendre conscience
du courage des enfants et des efforts
qui sont capables de déployer
ils m'ont montré
qu'un enfant en situation de handicap
peut être un élève compétents et même
parfois un excellent élève
ils m'ont fait interroger sur cette
norme à laquelle on demande à tous les
enfants de se conformer et qui pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux les gènes et
les empêche de se construire en tant que
futur adulte responsable et autonome
grâce à eux j'ai changé ma façon de
faire avec mes filles lorsque l'une
d'entre elles ne fais pas ce que je lui
demande de faire avant de nive de
m'énerver et de me dire elle ne veut pas
faire je commence par me demander est ce
qu elle peut le faire on pour tous
changer notre comportement vis-à-vis des
enfants quand un enfant ne fait pas ce
que vous voudriez qu'ils fassent
chercher la situation de double tâche
cognitive chercher là avec lui
et une fois que vous l'avez trouvé
ensemble chercher les solutions pour la
contourner
pour qu'enfin il est une chance de
pouvoir faire ce que vous lui demandez